yellow welcome to our live show here on
may 30 yeah I don't need to count down
I'm already life yeah hello to all of
the regulars in the chat I'm glad to be
on there on monday evening and down
happy to play a couple of blitz games
yeah going to shoot raw some five
minutes yes don't know what my rating I
said the moment I've played I last
played some games a couple of days ago
when i recorded from a channel but it
was pretty busy after that so yellow to
internet chess club who elders on
gudgeon school in a genius misko oh and
hello to bioshock right sir yeah a
question already what do I think of
Jeremy Salman's books have I read any um
yeah I think I have the reassess your
chest I think it's what I have no it's
pretty ok what I didn't like so much
about the book is the the way things are
organized it it always felt a little bit
messy to me but it has lots of useful
information you just have to be yeah
kind of when organizing reading I think
there are other books that are easier in
terms of structure but starts it's good
content ok playing the chick the Chico's
Chico's okay I'll play d4 and see what
happens hmm played him before she shows
Chico's I don't know how that would oh
this is pronounced correctly it's
playing a king's indian it seems mmm
yeah i play the same ish again i
recently discussed this a little bit
with a student so why not go for this
line again
22 all looks very normal yes you five I
think he looked you one is an idea not
going for I'm d 5 i'm not going to play
the Kings gambit definitely not and okay
so be six ok I think I have a couple of
moves that I can play here ok what about
this I wonder FG five now is a little
bit better than it was before b5 think
I'm pretty ready for be 595 is also not
such a big deal I think I can do that
the big drawback of the sameish
variation against them against the Kings
Indian is the delayed development of the
Kings side especially that Bishop and
night they I mean this is a king side
step at night take a while to get into
the game my idea is that I should be
ready to take be five if you tell if he
plays it and if I I just I just need
some moves if I get bit should be two
castles and a four blankets in bad shape
interesting well very interesting move
he tries to UM disturb my night hmm i
don't want Bishop d3 I don't want him to
trade stuff tough
hmm strong move I don't want to lose any
more time okay I'll do that anyway h4 is
so annoying there's a question if there
is a point in solving puzzles on a real
board instead of the computer screen I
think there is one problem problem is
you manage to solve less puzzles so you
can do more online but if you earn if
you do most of your work on the computer
but still play over the board lot then
never doing it on a reader board really
is a problem yeah it can be a problem I
always have this issue when I play over
the board blitz chess that I'm kind of
rusty I do worse over the board then I
do online nowadays um and it's just
because you have this three-dimensional
board of course instead of a
two-dimensional board and the difference
is kind of big okay h3 is a good movie
but take it that's not our three so I
have to go at four and I hope that my
central position here is good if it
takes on g2 Bishop g2 at least I'm
getting developed quite quickly that's a
good question what time control should
intermediate players shoot for to play
real chess online reopen at the
definition I I understand your question
it's it's a good one I think that a
rapid time control with some some
increment makes lots of sense something
like 30 minutes and some increment is
good if I've now is played to
when you cannot take you to d6 and I
want to prevent a knight coming from to
f6 maybe this is too straightforward I
don't know but I want to be quick about
about his player display on the King
side yeah interesting and now he's
probably threatening to take it so my
idea was aged 3
okay I'll go for it he will go to age
six possibility of five I wasn't
completely sure what to do now we need
three a snide f5 I think mmm how do i do
how to play that 94 takes Queen B 2 hmm
not sure maybe 83 wasn't that great
tough the same okay i think i'll
probably have to Castle him that is to
use the diagonal and a half potentially
a d6
ok now that move I didn't anticipate it
all I can do this this is a nice tactic
partakes fe5 dfi Brooke f6 so I get some
dynamic play out of this nice
I there's some cool questions in the
chat about big open tournaments like the
world open or Gibraltar yeah Gibraltar
hmm it's cool chess wise but I'm not so
sure that you can do that much besides
playing chess Jim this is a big problem
pawn takes rook f6 oh wow 27 GMS in
chicago over memorial day for a
tournament that's cool
yeah black is busted now it was
dangerous for him i'm not sure about the
objective married of my my play but it
definitely was dangerous home okay 95 i
guess the hotel inch brought has already
booked out that's funny it's super
expensive also check black resides
dangerous positioner for black I don't
know of this game it was so interesting
so let's see foreign game if you want
the tournament to suggest you to play
which is fun maybe where we can all
travel to one turnover gem here in the
chat what about the bunratty chess
festival yeah going to Ireland have some
good Guinness and would be something
game started making no sense I knew a
lot about that but let's see what this
game brings okay there's a question
about ka that i made a video on the
night of an intro video about this
opening and he said he says it seems
very complex and requires lots of
memorization yeah this is definitely
true
I'm not sure I think been ready might
not be rated yeah that's maybe true yeah
it's usually associated with heavy
drinking but it seems interesting now
he's playing all the moves in a split
second here mr. making no sense geez six
this is the main line in my book and I
have forgotten everything d 6 I can take
now check
nine f5 they don't do that I just wonder
about it twins is six is to move good
night f5 what am I playing against that
like we never 6i guess okay Quincy six
Bishop e7 Queen a form is the normal
continuation and then black has a choice
i think if i remember correctly what my
book says between age five and not
yourself I mean I could look it up I
have a copy somewhere okay now a este he
has taken it
so Queen a for now I have this vague
recollection that age 5 is strong in
this position clared make some sense
let's go age 5 i'm learning the night
off or sub 1600 players i would just I
wouldn't recommend it to be honest it's
immensely difficult to do to learn and
you will very often not get the absolute
main line so H for queen Knight takes
Queen have six yeah I'm bunratty you can
also play a less The Weekender and
there's something a bit more serious
with with those norms and stuff but i
think the non-serious is more
interesting yeah bunratty urban register
the name of the castle and the town I
think okay let's see if I can get enough
here I've got to I've sacrificed two
pawns it's easy to get to it's easy to
get to you fly to to Limerick is that
true not Limerick there's an airport
nearby for those people who want to fly
I would actually would like to try to
get down by them by am but train and by
the ferry yep that were also would be
cool it looks very attractive yeah they
play in that castle and they have
guinness and you never should
underestimate dad okay so um here I'm a
pond at two points down but I have this
amazing bishop
so maybe this is giving me some
compensation let's go here and now
Knight f6 and stuff yeah it seems that
he's defending this well I probably have
not remembered this correctly I'm not
totally sure Eddie night h5 maybe it is
threaten some stuff Bishop t6 I can take
g3 a couple of times yeah it's it's long
by ferry and train but it's far more
classy than just some stupid plane so
Queen f2 cool hmm take hero chief for I
don't see how that wins if I go look f80
in this position I don't know if I
winner it looks very dangerous I have to
be Bishop t6 I wanted to play with rook
air-five but then he has check on the
aid maybe that just queen to age 3m I
might be able to take it
I bloody chicken you ate
I don't see a great move here at the
moment probably i'm just not technically
good enough to spotted 93 okay i'm going
with this but i don't see a move after
Bishop t6 which is kind of embarrassing
there is probably something I cannot
take this actually 93 of course I'm just
a bad tactical player sometimes and okay
Bishop takes you can actually play mmm
it should be 693 Bishop g3 see you when
really don't look at five this rookie
aid unfortunately and this is the
problem
and when he has to take the six I think
rook air-five looks far too dangerous
why am i overlooking something after
Bishop d6 I don't see move after that to
be honest I wanted to take g3 and just
play this position but I don't see you
when really don't time morning I don't
see when ok five looks great but he has
rook e8 unfortunately check check
I'm in opinion this is the problem I
don't tell me I'm losing yeah that would
be powerful probably am losing wonder
what a nonsense game from this great
position I just have rookie vocation
maybe I'm surviving twin d to check
check check whoa check check check check
check check late what the heck this is a
kind of game that is frustrating you
kind of one step away from checkmating
and don't you don't see it maybe there
is no mate the engine doesn't find
something just a quick look remarkable
it looks absolutely absolutely dangerous
here yeah anyway let's go for a new game
and see what happens in that ok gain
started just in chess here yeah and I
want to get back over 2400 always feel
bad from below it so let's see if i can
get a winnin in this one yeah a non
night off sicilian for 1600 player yeah
things like know something like the time
i love is a little bit simpler or some
dragon if you want to go form and if you
want to go for the sicilian in the first
place ok very sharp
line and I have 3 News oh I actually
didn't want to do this but okay I e5 now
is the critical move
check yeah but it doesn't make any sense
to play them to play the poisoned pawn
line in the night off if you are a 1600
player I mean even though people have
problems with wider to play it I
understand that you also have problems
with black to play that just immensely
immensely tricky and the time you spend
two to learn this line in the first
place is better invested to learn some
real chess yeah like some ending for
example something like that okay so yeah
I'm trying to get rid of this bishop on
c8 and at the end to try to play against
whites pond in the center this a three
move is something that people on have
played against me before and I don't
think it's particularly great but I
never really studied it I should have
done so it just played play too often to
to be ignored ok so what to do now I can
go d5 196 that's six problem
24 it was good i don't think that
bunratty event is some expensive to plan
last time I looked it was it was ok i
never really i was checking this
tournament for a couple of years but it
never really worked because um there was
some kind of i had a had a team match I
had whatever yeah it was always
something
yeah i'm shooting for rugby to hear the
night night is probably just going down
and prophylactically maybe 95-93 as an
idea here and I might have go into the
sixth cervical 9526 to the move though
anyway context III which doesn't really
look that brilliant
random jelly says too bad you can smoke
at the board anymore Wow no I really
don't think that this is a good idea
smoking at the board I think it's it has
this kind of iffy if you see pictures
nowadays of TOWIE are sitting then in
the Olympiad yeah he has a big ashtray
besides him and it looks like he smoked
like two packs already it seems kind of
ours fields it's kind of romantic if you
see this kind of picture like it has
this yeah it's kind of it's kind of cool
to see to see the past them but you
don't really want to play against
somebody was smoking at the board I can
absolutely assure you this is no fun I
mean when I was still playing when I was
playing as a kid this was still allowed
and it's pretty awful okay so here ya
okay 95 but i thought that i should have
compensation there maybe not maybe this
isn't that great yeah i should speed up
this is quick and quite important and i
can take you five i can go here let's
see he's got the e4 square unfortunately
for his night
q1 can check if I fear also for
potential attacks like a Knight f3 and
stuff it's got 26 though I can also do
this first but maybe this is right gain
the temple yeah eating at the boys also
pretty terrible should shouldn't be done
I mean it'sit's kids clear that you
should eat something during the game but
it you should just do it while not being
at the board wow this is working it
looks terribly weak the back rank look
you won shik maybe it is working life's
not fair I don't and it's got a ton of
check stem cell okay I'm going to take
this
try it for Queen III and still the check
is part of it mmm
I don't know why I don't see something
super inspira morning check Brooke
everyone I don't see a win check check I
actually threatens to take Queen Queen
d2 maybe he's got check there but it's
just a check maybe you can check it on
e4 at the end wow it looks pretty good
they made on g2 is stuff Queen a check
though king of slight resides really I
wasn't sure you I was linked attack this
made me check check and okay i saw that
i can go to g5 it looks kind of scary ok
so i won that game who um game started
yeah I don't play the SH leftist laughs
come on this is the most boring opening
ever I'll play one year for ya this is
more interesting against super Mouse
from wit nom is that right yeah let's
play the fantasy variation that's a bit
more interesting than the selectors
laughs even though i don't know it I
don't know that line let's see if what
happens i think queen d three io is i
think this is how it is played something
like that at least is is possible
oh that's a question why do I never play
the Scandinavian defense and yeah i can
tell you and I think it's an ok opening
it really is it's not so bad but there's
the the general pawn structure with ENT
porn traded and this is something that I
don't like that much to play I mean I
think it's perfectly okay but it's not
my kind of position I simply prefer
positions where I have more where I can
do more in terms of porn levers I'd
rather have a more closed position that
i can open later and I don't like that
immediately half open position that much
for my own kind of game my own kind of
play that doesn't mean anything in
general it's just something that I
personally don't like that much okay now
g5 is hanging and I'm kind of under
attack here mmm sure not so great not so
great yeah playing this kind of offbeat
variation maybe it wasn't a great idea
my position sucks yep ID can just take
g5 that's not the only only thing but
the advantage and disadvantages of the
slab is actually the same thing you get
the same structure and this is good if
you want to limit let's say what you
have to look at you only have this one
structure that you that you deal with
but the bad news is also you have this
structure like every every game yeah
it's always this equal on traded for the
deep on and it doesn't have a huge
variety of position types so you're kind
of Wow of my position sucks wow I cannot
even go to be three because of Bishops
you for bowel ah that means I'm totally
loose in the area oh well that was a bad
opening so the Scandinavian eats to the
same pawn structure every single game
and you know it's kind of kind of bad I
think a bit boring if you have the same
structure every time and it's AB
structure that I personally don't like
that much this is the thing I get the
same structure that I don't like every
game so this is why I don't play it but
it's not a bad opening what is black
doing here is he really is giving stuff
back I don't know why I mean he can but
I don't quite well yeah it's good for
him the l a-- cons defense is
interesting it's interesting opening
especially if you want to play em
somewhat unconventional position maybe
trying to win the game whoo 93 is awful
94 93 night rook takes a five-night f1
mmm it still sucks I don't have a good
move anyway I probably have to do this I
sometimes play the calcaneus hmm it
depends on what my opponent term is
playing in the caro-kann if they play
some some sideline that I'm not so
scared scared of I tend to play this
opening but I never played the caro-kann
if I know that my opponent is going to
play the advanced variation for example
this is really not fun to play against
if you don't know the theory wow what an
awful position it's probably just
completely lost don't don't see exactly
how but it should be lost 93 Roxy one I
managed 94 and kind of develop maybe
it's okay and the cons defense is just
slightly better for white it's nothing
terrible about it maybe you can play p3
or what takes maybe not see to even
pretty awful the good thing is I'm ahead
on the clock hmm wow this is some
progress a little bit at least
and I met on the clock when the helical
is not refuted with the position
Alliance white is better but it's not
it's not something super serious what
did what a dreadful pollution really and
you should get the slide out cannot
cover they upon him
ok
yeah I'm still alive somehow it's not
good but at least the game continues I
would like to do something with the
night something a bit more dangerous
than just sitting there don't see it
don't see something though time morning
knight c6 doesn't do much actually but
whatever intending 96
look Kim one look aged seven just a
little little trick Oh didn't see that
one coming
the chick doesn't do much though check
probably check check check yeah it's so
easy to win the cessation now while that
was dreadful is I absolutely dreadful
where that that opening probably not
shouldn't be played by people who have
no idea about it Wow okay I should do
something be like a cut wide account
should do something a little bit a
little bit more serious so I've got a
new mo no Queens gambit okay Queens
gambit accepted is pretty good it's a
pretty good opening there's nothing
wrong with it at all I mean the only
line that takes a little bit the dead
makes blacks life difficult Izzy 43
before in the accepted and this is
rarely played on the amateur level so
especially for amateur players the
Queens gambit accepted makes quite some
sense and there's a question training
for opening middle games and games
tactics how does this change as you
progresses in strength of intermediate
to master level and the opening part
increases um to the point where let's
say on the GM level it's like eighteen
ninety percent of opening play
if you go further down I think if you
are let's say 1600 or 1700 if you do
twenty or thirty percent openings it's
it's cool and you have other things to
worry about especially middle game
planning and tactics tactics which means
calculation is important for absolutely
all kinds of level of play and all
phases of the gamer you need to
calculate well in the ending in in every
part of the game yeah Black is taking
ages here to put on this main line I
think castles looks very normal here I
mean okay maybe you can go see five or
something but
yeah here White has a little bit more
space black place in five and usually
retains quite decent chance to equalise
here be five is the most testing move
but I don't know that mouth this is what
played in the island Carl's and match
now I don't know it careful does a bit
lame but it's what I know you can get to
international master by being completely
self-taught you mentioned Jonathan
Hawkins I can also mention myself I
never had any formal training did
everything on my own it is possible but
it will always um yeah you will invest
lots of time on things that you don't
need to do and a coach can help you a
little bit with what you should do with
higher power priority whether or not
tongue twister what about be fine now
maybe that doesn't lead to much but ok
let's do it takes Queen takes I goes
back okay let's do let's take that
probably this is equal ish
is playing in extremely slowly it's
night there okay so button what's the
deal maybe this was a little bit easier
to play yeah definitely but I don't see
a clear way for me to make some headway
I can stick put something on c7 but it
doesn't necessarily do that much maybe
you can just play Gwynn to be 7am
I mean I don't see how we will ever
manage to not lose on time but what is
the sky it's no name amazing time
management is completely relaxed about
losing one time okay there any anything
in the chat not really in the Queens
gambit accepted if you if you feel like
you're comfortable with the 34 line then
it's absolutely absolutely cool opening
it's totally totally fine and okay what
happens here antique it probably should
take it I don't get on the see file that
easily though
well he cannot play rook c8 so maybe
this one preparing look see one
interesting play though maybe I should
have played a form that it was something
that crossed my mind but ultimately I
didn't do it okay so night c7 doesn't do
much he might have take the no gave 50
interesting yeah the Queens gambit
accepted it's not a bad opening to to
learn form for beginning players
absolutely it's not bad it leads to
mostly peace play it's very active no
it's it's fine I don't really know what
to do in this position to be honest yes
defended this quite well
we are probably as rook c8 so get a
strong move preventing 92k now look c7
as an idea it's good night c for AP
plate is very well just very slowly 95
hmm okay hmm I don't like to go back to
h2 it's kind of a very weak weak
background which probably still okay so
let's push this back and now isn't there
something there time 186 and stuff and
shooting 497 no just most look Wow
okay I should just speed up not just be
practical about it we need to been on
time check check check check black for
this on time I just was far too slow
yeah but he played as well I mean I
didn't really look that closely anymore
when I was clear that was when it was
clear that I was winning on time it's
it's it's tough checking that's quite
some discussion in the chat between
started some some viewers not so much
like a question for me so yes again the
question if I has to actively try to get
to the Grand Master title and no not at
the moment and probably I won't I really
i mean i have so many interesting things
that i have on the agenda yeah creating
a chess content doing the coaching or
all kinds of things and i enjoy them
actually more than their know then
playing to be honest i mean i don't mind
to play of course but it's a quite often
i'm given the choice I'd rather rather
write something then then play play my
own play myself ok yeahhh mister
harmony 1957 he went for them for the
orangutan sir rare opening but it's
probably equal white has to work a
little bit though against the type of
line that I'm playing here black's
pieces are very very active I no problem
if some question was asked that has been
asked before in the stream that's no no
issue you're not going to nobody watches
all of all of it all the time okay
Bishop g6 I mean I don't know it was
strictly necessary as a form wasn't a
thread yet but it might become a threat
my idea is just to develop community Sam
Luke the aid put pressure on white
center
was the hardest player have played in
life games you amuse the strongest you
mean probably I've played a couple of
strong players I have not played some
one rated 2700 when I actually played
them I have played some players who have
been about 2,700 Luke from Valley for
example just a couple of month ago I
played me huh gurvich and actually
beaten that was very nice result he was
number five in the world at one time
which was great yeah great to beat such
a player I still believe that I only
beat him because he had a heavy hangover
so yeah enter played a couple of and I
can play Joel OTA also was close to
2,700 played him twice actually lost
both games pretty badly I know I never
played our to you support that would
have been a cool experience I definitely
know
93 goes okay
only on just a three there's a question
if a player over 1,600 wishing to
serious improve should totally frame
from blank blitz and focus in 30 minutes
plus games and it's not a bad idea to
play many of those on those rapid games
but there's no problem with playing
blitz I don't think it's a bad idea to
play some blitz I hope that works it
looks very shaky takes Bishop takes only
5 65 I have 94 should be pretty strong
his Queen doesn't have any squares
yeah I should do another another match
you're totally right but currently I
cannot simply cannot get it done I have
some projects and you have some projects
currently going on and also some private
stuff that that takes time so it's it's
tough to organize yeah you should play
some blitz not like five hours a day
okay 94 wins the Queen he will when he
will get some stuff for it but this wins
the Queen check so what to do here be
sure to g6 song and so it's got a night
night upon and the rook for it okay I
don't like that he's got seasick CM I
can just take on the five is there some
issue with that famous last words
probably let still think I can do it
check I actually miscounted okay this is
good for black but I thought it what
would be better I thought it would be
just very good for me and this isn't the
case
how did germany get bit by stool
slovakia and football and well a couple
of things first of all i think that it
that bad weather didn't help him in the
second half but i think slovakia played
a very decently i mean i think they
played very decently it was I think the
goals in the first half Wilbur little a
little bit on the lucky side we I think
even if you are from Slovakia you would
probably agree check oh wow losing this
is pretty awful oh come on I didn't pay
any attention after that that that that
Queen win Wow awful yeah what is what a
what a [ __ ] kind of game sorry for
that black resign oh it's restrain this
is just a completely rubbish opening and
black just win see I just have to be a
bit careful now anyway come on game ah
what I gasps oh my gas on a live stream
la this is like this is fantastic right
so let's see what we so what's the deal
I'm just going to play I mean okay I'm
honestly I'm just going to play one of
his super boring openings and make a
draw yeah it's just what I do nowadays
against this against this play
I'm sure that was the most precise move
water I've played this against him a
couple of times already and I'm still
totally amazed that he keeps going for
this line because I'm lucky I mean this
is the most boring stuff ever Getty he
keeps playing this yeah whatever the
main point is you just have to play
quickly and don't try to find any big
things just nothing happens here this is
the the main thing I don't know just
doesn't matter just don't don't start to
think and try to find something great
there's nothing simply nothing going on
yeah of course I keep playing this
because I just get a draw I mean he's
like 25 something and I can just get a
draw every game i've gained rating
points
so what's the deal trust invader yeah
that's true now you cannot force a draw
I think in his opening repertoire sir is
very well thought out for this kind of
boring game and i don't i don't have
something really great against his lines
this is the problem a little bit i would
like to get sharper games but i don't
simply because i don't have something in
particular against his openings check
hmm looked each way i can come around
there may be back to the trade King c6
can be five I don't think I want that
she tried to go around down maybe it's
not idea i really ask us he's got a
little something now which is more than
you should have
yeah yeah that's not great I played it
to passively as it sometimes happens now
usually I just played Ross on this from
this line but this is not good
I can he can do this no I crap check
check check
just continue to now yeah I played it
just terribly you should never do that
position but ok I think I see is good in
endgames definitely and I played it
carelessly check
yeah it's not a nice end to the streamer
losing against this [ __ ] I really hate
the guy it's just what it is check okay
I'd like to quickly check I mean okay I
drifted into him it was a bad idea
probably to let him take down before i
take the and take the bloody bloody a
foul and something like that problem I
mean the worst part is that while it's
rather a little bit better than a little
bit worse probably something like that
yeah this is probably just good what is
he doing against this pawn this one like
p.m. ma'am anyway I shouldn't lose this
but it's it's it's always tough against
him any places he plays well on the
ending I mean still that you shouldn't
lose them but maybe 90 form of the bad
idea yeah yeah I'm drifting into a
passive position yeah this is wrong I
wanted to gain a little bit of space but
it's probably wrong and I don't gain
space but this is already this is
already uncomfortable Abby for porn is
weak and stuff now that's an
uncomfortable position definitely is
yeah I mean you know is it really not
possible to play some line that it's
known to none of you yeah I can do
something else um I can do something I
can't play something completely non
theoretical maybe this is the the other
the other thing I mean usually I just
make draws with this kind of game recent
games i just drew everything against him
and don't do the question why do I hate
him because he just plays a look again
struck on time opposite everything on
time everything on time and yeah I mean
auntie is also on the record for some
pretty foolish behavior you can just
google if you want google or like crevo
nuts off and I Rudolph and you get all
the information that you need is just an
idiot okay I am closing the stream here
and sorry about the rent but no I'm not
playing the grope it's not a good idea
and yeah okay I hope you enjoyed the
stream anyway and I'll be back next week
next Monday same time same place yeah
thanks for watching guys bye bye